[Music]
your kids do you think you're gonna be
interested in being doctors they showing
any signs of noticing I have a my middle
daughter I have three daughters my
middle daughter just turned six when she
was five she she's five six she's six
now she just turned six but when she was
five just a few months ago we were we
were driving around and I'll never
forget this I I was driving she was in
the backseat in her car seat and I was
driving and I caught a glimpse of her in
the rearview mirror and all of a sudden
as a dad you know you you almost didn't
catch a glimpse of your child and you
start to wonder you know what what life
has in store for them and never forget
you she picked up the stet there was a
stethoscope sitting there and she picked
it up and started playing with it and I
thought to myself that this this is the
moment just tell people later on that
this is when she decided she wanted to
become a doctor and she puts a
stethoscope and she puts it in her ears
and she's playing with it
I'm watching her very excited then she
pulls the other end to her mouth and she
says welcome to McDonald's can I take
your order you've done this before and
it's always fascinating you bring a a
scan a medical scan to try and educate
me and to try and see if I can guess
what the problem is did you bring
something today yeah let's just do one
because we don't have much time but all
right can you show me one right now
there you go
take a look at that that's easy I can
tell that's a human brain there you go
yeah and it looks like a mouse got in
there I would say a mouse guy becomes
like a Rorschach don't you see him Andy
do you see this I was gonna make the
same joke I was I was gonna say that's a
mouse and a brain that's not a joke oh
serious it looks to me like a mouse
climbed in someone with someone's asleep
a hobo and in a mouse guide in the ear
and a mouse is sleeping and hoping no
one finds it I think it looks like a
snake covering a face
I could see the problem here yeah dr.
koop don't want to talk to you later on
is kind of a fixation so what does that
say that's a blood collection in the
brain that white stuff is blood and that
actually is something that's caused by
hypertension people who have
hypertension that's not control they
never see their doctor they can develop
a believe that is what now is that fatal
or is this person gonna be a person's
actually doing well but this is
sometimes the first time they know that
they have high blood pressure is when
they develop a problem like that so that
this person was you know came to the
hospital and and we're able to control
their blood pressure and they did well
but you know just a reminder to people
how significant some of these problems
could this is also reminder to me that
I'm not a neurologist cuz I would have
said I would have instead of treating
that I would have held cheese outside
their ear for months it it an idiot